Dean Blandino works for Fox NFL rules
analyst former head of officiating for
the NFL and he joins us on short notice
good morning Dean thanks for joining us
let me ask you about this sky judge and
what is being proposed what is it
supposed to be and what it's going to
turn out to be in your opinion yes this
came from two clubs actually the charges
and the Ravens got together and there
were two proposals one one was called a
booth umpire that that could help the
on-field crew obviously sit upstairs use
video to help with administrative things
clock issues and then there then there
was a second concept called the star
concept senior technology adviser to the
referee that would get involved in more
subjective calls player safety fast
things like that
so really you know it's taking the PI
review that we had last year and adding
some elements to it and allowing someone
upstairs with access to video to help
the young field officials as they
officiate the game but there was no call
on the game with New Orleans and the
Rams could the sky judge initiate
something that the officials didn't call
on the field so the way the way it's
been proposed right now it doesn't look
like pass defense would be a part of
that and again this is this as far as I
know is not going to evoke for a regular
season rule this would be a preseason
experiment you look at it during the
preseason kind of work out some of the
kinks and then potentially in 2021
implemented but you also had helmet to
helmet on that play so they missed the P
I and there was a helmet to helmet could
the sky judge then say hey I got a
helmet to helmet guys because he can't
he can't bring up the pass interference
would that be safe to assume yes if the
sky judge had a hit on a defenseless
player then that would be part of the
the list of plays that they could get
involved in and so that play like you
said had two elements past appearance
which was which was obviously everyone
was talking about but like you said
there was forcible contact to the head
or neck area and that
is something that is in that list of a
place that the sky judge could get him
off I was told by somebody involved in
this process yesterday that there's a
concern that the sky judge could see a
lot of things elsewhere on the field and
then how involved is the sky judge going
to be he's Big Brother watching out but
should you be able do you have to go to
him or can he go to you if he says well
I got an egregious holding call against
Julio Jones on the other side of the
field we start talking about officiating
the game with video then you start to
see things right you can slow it down
maybe maybe there was a hold on Julio
Jones maybe maybe the left tackle
actually move prior to the snap where do
you draw the line and that's where I
think it becomes it becomes very
dangerous to get into this into this
realm we saw what happened last year
with P I review and now you start adding
these subjective fouls you know where do
you stop because at some point we got to
say look officials are gonna make
mistakes just like players and coaches
we have to minimize them but we can't be
really she a ting every play he's team
Blandino Fox NFL rules analyst and
former head of officials for the NFL as
far as replay goes how often would you
contact the officials on the field that
that we didn't know about went when
you're from the home office can you talk
about this now of how often you'd
actually do that sure look it would
happen from time to time I mean we had
we had a plan in place especially during
the postseason where if there was
something and this was going to be a
break glass in case of emergency
situation right this was going to be the
Saints Rams this was gonna be something
significant we're not talking about
something in the first quarter this had
end of game impact that we we had a cold
word I would get involved I would
communicate to the referee we would get
the officials together they would have a
conversation and we figure it out with
the help of the video right that's not
something that would happen very often
it would be in that isolated instance
where if this is a play that we're going
to talk about for years to come let's
get it right now
if it's not within within the realm of
the rule and let's deal with it now
didn't happen very often but but we did
have that in place what was the code
word and what's one of the plays that
you remember you know it wasn't you know
the code word probably changed from
referee to referee it was something that
we knew you know we established that
before the game it you know could be
Mayday Mayday and anything I don't
remember all the specific words could
have been Dan Patrick you know then you
you were big you're big in the
officiating of course I yes so that's
what you know some games we would use
oculi really really like juice you know
I remember there was one game I am NOT
gonna get into the particulars but there
was a there was a pretty significant
miss on a player safety foul that the
officials on the field missed we picked
it up in replay we saw it communicated
down to the referee after the play it
was a change of possession so we had
some time referee got the covering
officials together they talked about it
and they threw a flag
it happened late but it was the right
call again that didn't happen very often
but who knows if that had happened
during that Saints Rams game what you
know what would have happened after that
you know the Saints go to the Super Bowl
maybe we don't have a PI review it's
look it's not it's not an easy subject
that I know there's probably people that
feel you know on both sides of the fence
but that's something we felt was
important during that time but you're at
the home office you're at Mission
Control wait no so you have all these
screens there that you're watching and
then went when do you realize hey Dean
you got to see do you have people who
are spotters to then alert you to how
important to call is yes so every game
you'd have one person that's responsible
for monitoring that game if you have you
know an early window on Sunday you could
have 8 or 9 games going on so it's
impossible for one or two people to see
everything so you have one person that's
assigned to that game and they may call
you over if they see something they've
got experience they've been trained
some have officiating experience it was
easier during the postseason because you
only have one game going on at a time so
so everybody was on in that game I could
focus solely on that game and and you
were able to pick up more things but
again it was
we would only get involved outside a
replay if it was something significant
that was going to have an impact from
the outcome is this still going on that
Mission Control can then get a hold of
the head linesman or the field judge
whoever it is and says I got a mayday
here yeah I think it happens more with
administrative things the clock fixing a
spot but there's no question that's
happening there's communication the
on-field crew may check they may check
upstairs with replay and say what do you
think about that that this situation or
replay may see something but why did not
happen in the Saints Rams game Dean
that's a great question
I just I don't know I don't know look
it's easy to see here after the fact
I've been in that position I've been in
that position during Super Bowls and
championship games there's a lot of
pressure you know I would hope that if I
was in that same position I would have
done something it's easy to say after
the fact I don't know I don't know what
was going through you know the people in
the command center in their minds at
that time but obviously had it happened
things things were looking a bit
different today I don't know if you feel
the same way I've stressed this opinion
before I don't want all-star officiating
crews in the postseason I want you to
have my back for 16 games during the
regular season we know each other you
can come up to me and say Dan I think
you missed that one let's huddle up and
I don't take it personally I know that
you have my best interest at heart I
thought that the all-star officiating
teams maybe there is a lack of
communication maybe there's ego maybe
you don't want to embarrass somebody I
don't know if that factored in in the
Saints Rams game but it felt like there
was one of the officials is overbite
Payton and he he I thought he was gonna
run in to say hey you know we got
something here the official who was
right there during the play waves him
off and I just it struck me as strange
and maybe I'm over it but I I just think
the all-star crews I'd like that you got
rewarded
I'd rather reward a team for what they
do
during the regular season what do you
think yeah no there's no question look
I've been on both sides of that and I
understand
the crew concept obviously there's
probes that you've been working together
all year you you create that that bond
in that continuity and the communication
is so key because you've been doing it
all along whereas the people that like
the all-star crew they say well you know
you've been compensating for a weak
member of the crew a year do you want
that person in the biggest game of the
season you know on their own so I think
there's a balance there where you keep
the crew together as much as possible
but if you do have I guarantee if if if
we said to an NFL team look I'm gonna
take your worst offensive lineman and
I'm gonna replace him with a Pro Bowler
for this game they'd probably jump at
that but but again I like the continuity
of the crew I don't know how much that
went into that play I just think those
officials reacted maybe have they been
on the same crew there might have been
more communication again it's all
speculation at this point but but I do I
do understand the crew concept I think
you keep the crews together as much as
possible the XFL with the kickoff or
there's no onside kick and now the NFL
is toying with the fourth and 15 instead
of the onside kick what do you think of
this yeah it's a very positive positive
you know look I'm four I'm all for
change but I don't like change for just
change sake right I want I like the
tradition of the game I still think the
onside kick there's a chance you look at
the numbers yeah in 2000 in 2018 it had
dropped drastically because of the rules
changes but last year you know was up up
you know twelve thirteen percent which
is which is its historical number
I like the onside kick I don't like a
gimmick fourth and 15 I just feel like
there's a lot of you know unintended
consequences we have to see you know is
it a safer play nobody knows nobody
knows that fourth and 15 is safer than
an onside kick with the new rule
changes in terms of formation so I like
I like where it is I don't I understand
the reason I know we need teams to have
an opportunity to come back you want
closer games you want more exciting
finishes I just think there's a whole
host of things that have to be worked
out on 4th and 15 you know in that
situation what about penalties are you
replaying the down if the offense pushes
off and they get offensive past the
frame so we trying it again what about
the clock all of these different things
I think I would like for the league to
work those things out and and then and
then have a good healthy discussion over
the course of time before they implement
a drastic change like this Dean it's
always great to touch base with you tell
Mike that we said hello is prayer is he
behaving but you two live together right
I like that Dean thanks for joining us
that's Fox NFL rules analyst and he also
worked with the XFL